[Music]
bTW man yes thank you very much for
coming on I really appreciate it my
pleasure cuz it's probably been two
years since I've wanted to get you to
sit down and another discussion so here
we are here we are in the same hotel on
the same I know right
poetic justice there is so yeah I got to
hear you I turned up late my luggage
arrived a day late I had to run upstairs
and come downstairs to this black tie
ball thing that we had two years ago
here and then kind of burst into the
room and sat down as this guy got up and
stood up and it was you and you were
about to give this big speech and I was
like totally unprepared like wholly
unprepared and I guess like because that
was just after you've done your TV thing
as well right
and so I your notoriety was probably
riding moderately high and then being in
this community of authors everyone would
have had an idea of what was gonna be
said and then you just unloaded this
story and I was like totally you know
like someone rocks a bar with weights
that you don't know what it is you step
underneath it me like oh my god there's
really one IV yeah no no no too much too
much and uh yeah man I got I got blown
away by that well in the weird part was
that at that part two years ago you know
I had told my story with vests portside
co-founded in 2012 so telling my story
had become a thing over the years but at
that point within the community it
hadn't been a thing yet you know people
knew the basis of my story they knew I
was combat wounded veteran stuff like
that but they never knew the
eccentricities of my entire life and so
that's what I wanted to do with that
speech was just kind of lay it all out
there
mm-hmm and then kind of just give them
the whole narrative how different does
it feel giving the speech to the
industry that you're in now which is
authors versus the industry that you
were in order you you're associated with
which is veterans I well so that's
actually different than what I usually
do I don't talk to a lot of buttons on
force I talk to veterans but it's more
conversational good it's not giving them
you know a speech or whatever yeah so
the difference is where I'm at is that
speech was for my peers
the romance community right and usually
my other speeches are for businesses or
clubs or groups or whatever so for me it
meant a lot more because obviously being
a creative type you are you're used to
and you're you make emotions your
business yeah emotions are your business
you understand that you understand pain
and love and all these beautiful things
and so they for me being able to share
my story in that room the response I got
back was so much better and greater than
what I ever had before you think I've
got that depth of understand they have
that stat that exact perfect word for a
depth that they that compassion they're
just different people we're wired
differently as authors as creative types
angry oh yeah I mean it sounds like
hearing your story sounds like a work of
fiction yeah my videos like you lived it
serious so you know can you take us from
where do we stop ideal story why do we
begin
I honestly don't even know that's a
weird Perkis I touched on everything
with that speech I had a real fucked-up
childhood real bad childhood and a lot
of abuse of every variety and so when I
hit about 15 it was that point where I
was like I need to do something I need
to get the [ __ ] out of here I have to
get out of here what was growing up like
st. Louis Missouri is where I was born
and raised okay and so I had a lot of
members of my family in the military I
and I also attributed to this as well
Saving Private Ryan when I watched that
movie at 14 and I saw what those men did
on d-day
I was so profoundly moved by by their
strength that that was that point where
I was like I need to do that you know I
felt I owed it to them so at 18 I ended
up joining the army the army infantry
shipped off the Fort Benning Georgia
went through basic training graduated
went to Germany trained up for a year
and then ended up in Iraq what is what
is this what we're talking now so 2004
was basic training 2005 was Germany
training up for Iraq and in 2006 was
Iraq so you're right in the middle of it
yeah oh yeah so yeah 2006 was the worst
year in Iraq actually whether in terms
of biometric okay
like in terms of kie and then also
wounded they why non-stop why so what
happened with Iraq was we it's kind of a
complicated complicated but General
Colin Powell yep said at the beginning
of the Iraq war that we need to close
off the borders we need to close off the
borders because what we're gonna do is
have a free-for-all we're invading Iraq
and if we do not protect these borders
you're gonna have every swinging dick
yep from the Middle East coming in to
fight reinforcements yep
guess what happened almost everyone we
killed or captured was not Iraqi but
from some other Middle Eastern countries
that was around about that came in there
they're like hell yeah they're gonna
fight to us let's go
it's like [ __ ] Red Dawn Middle
Eastern style yeah and so yeah it mean
they came in and it was just hell I mean
it was absolute hell and then you had I
ran backing them with weaponry what I
got hit with was called a EFP
explosively formed projectile and it was
developed by Iran very basic
mechanically but very very like credibly
effect incredibly so let's roll it back
so you've gone through your basic
training okay how did you feel how were
you excited to go out there we all know
this we yeah you all ready to go yeah
yeah I joined I mean I literally when I
went in maps is where you go to like a
sign up and you just do your paperwork
and you get your physical and all that
stuff so I went in there and you came
time to pick your job and so you take an
as verb test which kind of dictates what
jobs you can get oh so as long as you
score 110 on your GT it's not like an
aptitude pretty much aptitude test and
as long as you score 110 on the main
part of it you can have any job and I
scored 110 so I had all these job
options and we're going through them all
and I look at the lady and I'm like who
are the guys that going like kicking the
doors and [ __ ] and raid houses no she's
like well that's infantry I'm like yeah
I want to do that yeah and it's just
like are you sure she's like there's
like a lot of other jobs here's
intelligent I'm like yes you would you
have been able to be infantry it like a
105 or a hundred
okay so infantry is the one where if you
score freakin 85 you're going infantry
ok amateur Co it's right date really
like the lowest a little oh right okay
which is why she was like you sure
you've pitched yourself here super high
but actually that's what I wanted to
[ __ ] do I wanted a fight that's
that's the only thing I wanted to do so
yeah I was AI was amped
absolutely amp basic training for me was
life-changing
I went in a boy came out of man like
there's no better like better way to say
that than that doesn't say as it is it's
true as [ __ ] I went in and just this
little [ __ ] Punk
disrespectful little punk and I came out
just completely changed you'd said that
you'd had a difficult childhood a
difficult youth did you start to find a
little bit more of a sense of purpose
there as well
absolutely absolutely yeah so and a
family so it was the first kind of
family I felt and their life the family
up until then it may be no wasn't him
loyally yeah the definition of family
was very off and so yeah it was just
this bond this love that I hadn't felt
before this Brotherhood and it's yeah it
energized me and and then obviously
going to my new unit I talked to my
buddies about it all the time but you
know that feeling of youth right where
the whole world is out in front of you
and it's just everything's there and
it's beautiful man and I'll never forget
getting to Germany fly in there and I
was actually cry and then Baltimore when
I was heading out to Jeremy because I
was scared you know scared of leaving my
family and leaving everything behind
change is a scary thing yeah
and when I got the Germany bro my god
I'm telling I was on the bus going from
the airport to my new base and I'm just
just the feelings I'll never fresh a
salute rush so yeah I was ready I was
prepared it was it was a fantastic time
period of my life and then of course you
know you get into the unit and you're
it's it's a whole different lifestyle
change you're waking up well you do it
all your own free will now which is
crazy but you wake up 5:00 in the
morning and you you do Pte and then you
have Chow at 7:00 and then you go to
work day at 8:00 and you're off at 5:00
it's like it's just an except you're in
uniform and you're doing military [ __ ]
it's just weird it was just it was a
really cool point in my life that's
awesome so then you got deployed so then
you have lots of training in there and
that that that side of it was not fun
obviously it comes with the territory
but yeah months and months of training
of them how did you find that physically
tough tougher mentally but definitely
tough physically as well I mean you're
you're they're trying to get you with
that training you're out at a month of
time right and you're staying in tents
and it's pretty much just like Iraq's
gonna be because they want you to feel
it once you
explain this it's pointless having you
the sensation of 50% you need to a three
hundred and ten percent and then you if
you're playing for the NFL you're gonna
go straight from college into your first
game you're gonna [ __ ] practice yeah
okay so we practice our ass all our
asses off and that meant you know months
at a time staying in tents I can no in
entertainment working 12-hour days it
was rough but it's also obviously when
you get to combat you're like oh okay I
get it yeah you want I needed this
yep so so we ended up deploying I got to
Iraq again scared for sure you know
anybody who goes to a combat zone is
nervous scared but excited and excited
I'll never forget driving up from Kuwait
we did a mid middle of the night convoy
from Kuwait to Baghdad as I said Inlet
become these huh and a long row of
Humvees yeah I'm in the Gunners turret
just looking around just like and I
didn't know breath like there was they
weren't bad areas we were driving
through but I didn't know so I'm up
there like GI [ __ ] Joe I think
definitely for me like the as a as a
Brit stereotype of a American infantry
guy would be exactly that like yeah hard
on straight up yeah yeah just you should
see us in part one I close interrelation
enough during middle of a firefight when
no normal everyday people would be like
freaking out you're like weird bro it's
weird man it's weird you don't it's you
don't view death normally when you're
over there you don't see it as something
that can actually happen it's weird you
know it is you know it's like every day
it's it's it could happen but you don't
think about it it's like I think that's
one of the em that's one of the things
from having doing a lot of reading on
PTSD and stuff like that which we'll go
into later one of the things that I
think I've realized is that people
especially people that do that are in
the army but until they're out there
they don't appreciate their capacity for
malevolence and for aggression and it's
that reflection period where everything
slows down afterwards and you totally
right like in the heat of the moment
like look at look at what happens when
someone sees red and they're getting a
fight just a normal like a bar fight
like would you have punched this person
and like gone outside on the street amid
shouting and screaming and kicking and
going hysterical would you have done
that under normal circumstances no but
then you put someone into a very
specific situation with a very specific
set of emotions and they have the this
capacity that is far and away from what
you'd have thought originally just funny
you say that too and I know we're gonna
hit on it later but that is part of the
problem with PTSD is that you spend this
time in combat where you turn all those
emotions off that are necessary to be
human and the only ones you really focus
on our aggression and anger because
that's what you need over there you need
to have that because if you're on
already very very dead if you have to if
you have to make 10 every decision yet
if every decision was mediated by
compassion you you're not gonna last
right over matter at all
so you've driven up you've arrived
you've arrived and that's actually the
funny part of my story is that three
weeks then I got hit by my first ie D so
we had been on a bunch of missions and
stuff like that up to that point what is
the mission so going out at that point
it was route route clearance so what we
would do is literally just drive five
miles freakin hour up and down the roads
looking for IEDs okay and then if we
found something that was a potential ie
D we call EOD yo D comes out checks it
out it's what's the vehicle here it it
has a Humvee I was always in the Humvee
and then I had three missions and a
driving a Bradley which was cool tank
big that's a nice hmm
so yeah we're coming in from one of
those missions if things had been calm
to that point had you seen any action by
this bill no action yet at all three
weeks then and then we we take the road
turn on to the road to go and onto the
base and then blew up who hit my vehicle
it was about a mid-range one so it
didn't it didn't breach the vehicle but
the windshield completely shattered it
did breach the side of the my TC who's
the passenger side it came through his
window and went into his helmet like
right at the top he actually kept his
helmet and the goggles he had because
they are lined with shrapnel and he
didn't get hurt at all no way but that
was why we use because I was driving
okay and he was on the I was on the yeah
yeah opposite sides so yeah that was
eye-opener that was hey welcome direct
buddy how did the hot rake go by I it
was it was insane it was unlike anything
I've ever felt obviously until the other
ie D but it things slowed down
it was everything with slow motion you
know they you know see it in movies and
you hear people say it but it's just
absolute truth it's slows completely
down I saw the windshield crack like in
slow motion as it happened it's just it
was weird fascinating things slowed down
completely and then of course it stopped
and you're just like oh my god I'm alive
yeah yeah
and you just didn't like a Humvees just
a big car basically like very armored
garbage oh is it okay so very very
armored having the agree have armor yeah
okay so I mean that's that's saved your
life oh absolutely
yeah well five times over there yeah
yeah oh my god we got hit five times
that one was the second worse obviously
the one that did me in was the the worst
and then the other ones were kind of
smaller a homemade explosive types but
yeah they weren't super destructive like
professionally pretty you're still you
get you here next year via tile are you
reading it yeah okay
so you've had your first one is we had
our first one and that was that and then
you know we spent another year there and
lots of firefights lots of you know
again some smaller IEDs we lost some
guys unfortunately um we ended up losing
our first two guys April fools day
actually no / Fool's Day it was a couple
weeks after I got hit and they were
dismounted and got hit by an IUD and
it's not a dozen out of the Humvee okay
and then yeah so that that's another one
that was kind of like it's weird because
it's like stages in combat you know you
got your first introduction to combat
and then you you lose your first guy and
you have to process that and then you
have to process having to go back to
work the next day and pretend it never
happens you know what I mean again which
is where PTSD you manifest itself
because you can't properly mourn them
you haven't had time to do the reflect
you can't it's right because if you're
thinking about them the next day when
you're on mission you may end up putting
yourself or others in danger because of
it so well we discussed this briefly
yesterday when we was
when we sat down talking the period of
reflection that everything is so
important and that's why practicing
gratitude and trying to have a lot of
people in the normal world will confuse
busyness with success and that staying
busy constantly just moving in one
direction is somehow a marker for
getting things right but that's not
necessarily the way that you should look
at it because this period of reflection
allows you to realize what's going on it
allows you to internalize the situation
that you've been through and then out
the other side of it you have some
learning and okay I'm now ready for the
next one where is what you happen when
you deployed is you just have a batch of
experience for however many months or
however many years and then you get home
and you're like okay there is a [ __ ]
Amazon truck full of [ __ ] that I now
need to try and go through and we all
know that memory is one of the least
accurate ways of actually recalling
something like by the time that you're
two years deep and you've been through
all of this stuff the first thing that
you did like can you actually accurately
properly reflect on that probably not
like it's become confused and conflated
and and manipulated by all the other
things that you've been through and then
by the time you get home you got to go
back through it again so okay so we're
now one year deep yeah so well now one
year deep again it's the whole process
um lost our first you guys we ended up
losing eight total and and then we got
to October 22nd 2006 we're nearing the
end of the tour how much long is left
two days so we have two days left and
we're doing what's called a right sea
ride we're taking the new guys around
the area of operations and showing them
shown around getting them ready to take
over and yeah we were just routine
mission got hit and next thing you know
I'm I'm waking up and smoke though is
completely filling the Humvee there's
flesh everywhere just charred flesh all
over the windshield I had no idea I
didn't feel anything at that time
I'm just like I woke up I saw all this
so did you hear the bang or was it
there's a no it was like it was like I
heard the bangs was like
bang blacked-out right yeah and so I
woke up vehicles still moving
and I'm just like I have no idea what
road is up driving again okay so the
vehicles still moving I go to try to
break the vehicle and my right legs not
working like what the [ __ ] and I look
down and I see there's like [ __ ] hanging
out of my thigh so I know I'm injured
there I still don't feel it though
mm-hmm use my left foot to break that's
when my uh my gunner I looked back I'm
like are you alright he sees it on the
ground on both his legs are gone one of
his legs are sitting right next to me so
that's when the guy in the back I also
noticed the other we have five people in
the vehicle total three year passed out
two were passed out I'm sorry and then
us three me the gunner and the guy
behind me were awake guy behind me goes
hey can you please please open my door
please open my door can't take the smell
anymore unless you until you smell human
flesh you just don't understand it but
it's very distinct and it's it's you
Lynette you never forget it okay
so I lean back I open the door for him
because his arms were all jacked up and
I turned back around and that's when I
felt it that's when everything kind of
came to load a little yep had they
turned the pot killed me out here
even yeah it's the adrenaline but uh the
shock yeah the shock kind of started
wearing off and that's when it was just
like the most excruciating thing I've
ever felt in my life what had it ended
up happening was the the metal that had
gone in my leg was so hot that I was
cooking my leg from the inside oh my god
and so I up from the ie D always thought
from the Humvee so we're actually come
back around to the e fps explosively
formed projectiles is what I got hit
with we got hit with two of them now
what these are is there's a canister
like that right metal cook metal
canister surface a circle circular they
stuff explosives inside and on the end
they put this copper contact lens shape
this contact lens shaped piece of copper
okay it's right on the end when the
explosive goes off that copper turns
molten and shoots yep and so it hits the
side of the Humvee and eats right
through it breaks through each right
through and once it hits the AC on the
inside and hardened so it's like a
cannonball yeah so I caught I caught one
of the EF fuse that broke up into four
pieces so one was baseball sized one was
like quarter sized golf ball sized from
that then on and then I also was full of
plastic and the [ __ ] from the door
that had come into yeah but that's the
stuff that was cooking my leg was the
pieces of copper because that's what it
does it's designed to do but you said
there was two two on either side of the
road no on both sides
yeah so one stayed full and the other
one broke up if the other one didn't
break up I'd be dead I wouldn't be here
today
really yes because it didn't do the
damage that it should have the other one
didn't break up and it killed my buddy
it went back right George torso and was
that the gunner that was no that was my
pickup passenger the TC and that's the
side it came through one right okay Wow
yeah so so pretty much that's the point
where the pain kicked in and that's the
point also where I looked over at him
and knew that he wasn't gonna make it
yeah so I'm [ __ ] yelling the Gunners
yelling we're like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I mean
lots of pain going through this vehicle
yeah our guys come up from the other
vehicles and pull us out
that's about BIG's the convoy only four
vehicles at that point okay so they pull
us out we tell you what you would is it
point well-taken
yes we were point yep we were the first
in line which is that's major David
Taylor's the man who died that day and
that's that was his thing he wanted to
lead we said let them look if we're
gonna get hit or yeah it's gonna be us
and and so we're pulled out and this is
kind of the fascinating thing about this
and my story kind of revolves around I'm
very big believer in God I have a lot of
faith and these are thing my god moments
I feel like those are the moments that
they should not have happened and they
did so when we got hit there was a CIA
chopper flying overhead they saw us get
hit they came back around and they
medevacked us out had we not had that it
would have taken up to 20 30 maybe 40
minutes maybe longer to get a medivac
there my femoral artery was [ __ ] knit
so I easily like one of us easily could
have died there that day had that CIA
chopper not been overhead so the chances
of the happening uh slim does like
negative number might as well have no
existing pretty much yeah so you're
thinking act of God right act of God
absolutely yeah because they were it was
it was so weird man I'm telling you it's
at that point I had shocks that in
hardcore I didn't feel the pain anymore
I'm in
shopper right my buddies heads lane a
mile ow do you what happens how do they
get you out of the vehicle that will
they pull they pretty much carried us
really yeah yeah so you got my guides
there right so we have three other
vehicles behind us we've got a [ __ ] ton
of guys so their help and dragged us out
the guys on the chopper are getting us
in so me and my buddy al who was a
dismount he was behind major Taylor yep
he was passed out he hadn't lost his leg
above the knee okay
he's his head's in my lap I'm sitting in
the back of the chopper him smacking his
[ __ ] face trying to wake him up and
this is one of those little tiny
choppers the CI a Delta Force they use
the little baby Huey's they're super
small is there like a flat there's like
just a seat in the back so me and our in
the back okay the guy they're so badass
bro there's like just like a movie but
the guy there was two of them CIA guys
yeah and one of the CIA guys couldn't
sit in the back because we were back
there so he's hanging off the side the
[ __ ] helicopter all draft like
on [ __ ] GI Joe doubt dude and he's
just like just riding just watch just
ride oh my god and so I'm seeing this
when I'm in shock and slam so then this
is a funniest part where it's only a
short flight away but you know it felt
like forever I'm looking down over the
city of Baghdad as we're flying in
absolute shock and I feel like I can fly
like either legitimate at that time
thought I could fly and I almost jumped
out of the helicopter and right before I
was gonna jump out of the helicopter to
start flying I passed out probably just
as well
yeah pretty terribly just as well so I
passed out and then next thing you know
I woke up at the cache which is little
Combat Support Hospital in Baghdad every
major base has them little sport
hospital for when [ __ ] like this happens
okay so we get in their surgeries and
that's pretty much I mean that period of
time that five days from going from
Baghdad to balad to launch tool is that
you see is this you being rated up
through better and better equipped
medically medicals so it's that and also
stabilizing you so it's like that you
have the initial surgery right so you go
to the cash yeah they're cleaning you
out okay they do anything they may need
to do like right men in there fix the
femoral artery so that they they
hesitate it all necks they didn't know
it was knit
but they didn't know what to do yet they
didn't because obviously you don't want
to [ __ ] with a femoral artery and a
little Combat Support Hospital that's
the basis so we took him like a
basically a glorified tent in the middle
of the desert pretty much okay
so I was actually very lucky because I
didn't cut my Fromer artery but because
the shrapnel was so hot it cauterized it
immediately yeah so the shrapnel both
injured both injured and saved my life
how poetically weird is that crazy so
much justice in them that's unbelievable
so yeah you could you go from Baghdad
Combat Support Hospital to blog which is
again a big tent Hospital but it's legit
hospital in a tent okay huge yeah go
from below they stabilize you there you
go to launch tool where they finally
like settle you a novel is this still in
our our German II Germany right okay and
they said you get from Iraq to Germany
that was just c-130 okay yeah yeah they
have a hospital see what like just load
you in the back on a stretcher stretcher
yep so what would that what those
journeys like horrible that that that
whole time in my life was horrible
so was it was surgery to every single
day so I didn't get water I couldn't
drink water obviously because you have
to have surgery you can't drink water
before surgery you have IV so you're
getting hydrated yeah but it doesn't
change the fact that you're dying
listing so I'd be like [ __ ] on little
sponges of water and [ __ ] yep
made it out of surgery and then the
flights
you know the flights I don't really
remember the ones from Baghdad and Balat
but the one from Germany to DC was
that's like what are we 14 oh yeah it
was about honesty what a c-130 about
yeah about 13 and will entertain even 13
hours on a plane is difficult on an a380
with like calm polite service and with
limited gin and all the rest and you got
your movies and all that we didn't have
anything and then again you're you're in
a significant amount of pain too and
there's only three nurses on the whole
plane serving how I'm telling you you
should have that's you would be at 2006
I was one of about 150 on that flight
and you're talking about listen flight
this entire flight a stretcher stretcher
stretcher stretchered stretcher rows of
stretcher and
three hi all my girls were did their
tiered so it's like a good a football
game yep that's how many people were
injured back then and so the nurse is
like they're trying to do their best but
they can't hit everybody when you need
like when you need pain meds they can't
get to the eunuch in a reasonable amount
of time so yeah it was its who was the
worst fight of my life okay yeah
absolutely so now if you need to fly
some why do you just feel like this oh
it's blown in New Zealand a couple times
I'm why the Saints do butt heads
absolutely so what the what's the
medication that the guys are giving you
to suppress the pain immediately oh [ __ ]
I couldn't even tell you what the ones
were back then I can tell you in DC I
was getting dilaudid and morphine and
like the highest [ __ ] you can imagine I
I imagine back then I was I mean
probably heard those days something just
ridiculous because I was in and out of
it like legitimately just in and out of
it I was I was semi coach now living
yeah okay now that's how much to me
conscious because I knew what was going
on but I would just go in and out okay
so we get to DC YDC
Walter Reed on Walter Reed Military
Medical Center it's not because of what
you would deployed from ERISA because
that was the best facility for dealing
with its military medical facility so
they have the Army has - okay and it's
once in San Antonio young men ones in DC
so I guess you're a burn victim you go
to Texas if you're anything else you
usually go to be so fit and the kind of
opposite ends of the country yeah to a
degree I guess yeah right so yeah so we
ended up going to DC and at that point I
still have my leg so but it was just
trashed obviously and the firm already
was still kind of in limbo and it was
October 31st 2006 so we're talking
what's nine nine days later nine days
later it's Halloween and I I hadn't been
sleeping man I mean the lots and lots of
pain as you can imagine lots of pain
meds and so she's real bad insomnia and
then obviously you're starting to
realize what's happened - yeah which
again you actually you know you do as I
said you don't think about death over
there but you know it's it's a
possibility
you really don't think nor do you really
consider it a possibility of losing a
limb or getting injured like that you
know it's just not a
you really think about you know it's
there but it's just like you just never
really put yourself in that position so
I'm just sitting here like wow what now
you know yeah
October 31st comes around and it's 4
o'clock in the morning I'm 5 o'clock in
the morning I'm watching home
improvement on TV because I can't sleep
and all of a sudden you know I have all
these machines hooked up to my leg and
[ __ ] and one of them pumps the harmful
fluid out right okay starts pumping out
blood like real deep burgundy blood and
like no that's not good so I'll call a
nurse nurse comes in oh no big balls up
some towels and puts it under my lady to
put pressure on it
and about two seconds later the the
bandaging rips off and blood starts
[ __ ] spurting dude like [ __ ] three
feet into the air and I'm just like
tripping he's tripping now too like he
was all calm before and he just starts
freaking out there it is again there is
hmm and that next thing you know within
seconds my room is full of medical
personnel frantically working bloods
covered my sheets and almost what's
happened my firmer blue okay from artery
blowing they'd been nicked and it was
neck right I had been in a surgery them
clean and [ __ ] out and we just did it
was it can take the pressure anymore
couldn't take so just in the same way is
a like a a slow puncturing a tire then
high speeds turns into work yep oh yeah
okay so I can't explain the feeling but
it's almost like theatrical right it's
like oh you're in a [ __ ] movie like
is this my life right now am i bleeding
to death right now and like you know
you're getting woozy and the TV starts
like 3d now do you ever just so [ __ ]
and I remember begging them not to let
me die you know I'm just like don't let
me die don't let me die don't let me die
it's all I could say and I called him
mystery doctor but he was a he was an
african-american doctor a very handsome
man and he right here he pushed down and
where my friend role meets my order so
hard that it was sore for about a month
after and he saved my life had he not
done that from my room to the o.r I
would have died absolutely so he'd
stemmed the flow he stopped the flow
until I could get through the o.r where
they could get a tourniquet on me yeah
and and absolutely saved my life so I
get to the ole alarm was the
it was actually quite a bit so your I
went from I think that Oh ours were on
the fourth floor and I was on the sixth
floor so we literally he had to take me
from my ward all the way to the main
elevators down the elevator to the
fourth floor and then to the o.r and
he'd the whole time steady pressure the
whole [ __ ] time walking along the
guarantee she's difficult as you're
moving is really hard yeah and shall I
got to the o R and I remember them
freaking out and getting me on the table
I'm still like woozy but still with it
and you know just up here and they're
putting the tourniquet on and next thing
you know it's just I'm out and then I
wake up and I'm in the ICU and they're
staples all down this side I've got a
scar running the length of my leg
there's looks like [ __ ] Frankenstein
yeah and then this side is just new new
bandages and [ __ ] like that you're like
what the [ __ ] happened doctors in there
my parents are in there the doctors like
wow it's like you gave us a really
really good scare there they ended up
telling me that they my friend Marty
blue obviously I lost 2/3 of the blood
in my body
two-handed zat the blue yeah so what are
you talking now the eight pints probably
yeah so what was the 5.5 liters in the
human body so well in 180 pound human
body as well okay yeah yeah so yeah I
don't know a lot of blood how what's the
level at which you died I don't know
well I know you're right about 2:30 yes
so what they that what they did
immediately would seek our faint after
they give a pint
yeah of blood which is half of the liter
so if had that again if that had
happened and I've been Baghdad I would
have been dead yeah so thank God I was
in the hospital they can get blood up I
mean they started pumping blood through
me right then and there
yeah once I got the or so anyway yeah
woke up and said gave us quite a scare
there we ended up having to take though
a vein out of your left leg and put it
in your right to create a new there my
heart so your left leg vein vein my
right side right like the femoral artery
and they pretty much just flip it around
so they take it out here flip it and
turn into an artery no way weird ACOG
man it's greatly medicines
it's fascinating incredible so that's
another beautiful thing about it is I
lost six inches of my femur right so
when it went in went in right here blew
out this side I lost
above that much
my femur yep they had to take it out
there's just little pieces left they
grew my femur back using bone grafts and
stuff I had four different bone grafts
and they grew all of that back and it
looks [ __ ] crazy and weird and wicked
but it's a bone I run on it and all that
it's like it's just blows my mind well I
mean if for nothing else I got I've
given blood once but never that much but
you know hearing a situation like that
where someone's life gets saved by the
fact that they need circa five eight ten
pints of blood whatever it might be like
people aren't donating blood you're dead
and then that's I'm one person and I got
blood more times than I can even count
because most surgeries you know you go I
was I have I've had 37 surgeries and
most of those surgeries you come out of
you if you bleed a lot you need blood
dude I got blood probably about a
quarter of those surgeries and then
obviously with the femoral artery I got
blood I mean those eight some days yeah
yeah so yeah so I mean I woke up and my
life was changed man I mean I just I was
so fearful after that because I was like
what if I was sleeping when that blew
you know I mean what if it blows again
yeah what the [ __ ] am I gonna do so I
didn't sleep I thought I couldn't see
before that I didn't sleep at all after
not at all and so that ended up that's
the femoral artery blowing is why I lost
my lower limb okay I initially was you
know they thought I was gonna lose my
leg up here because where I got hit I
didn't have damage to my lower limb okay
but because of the femoral artery it was
a about a 14-hour surgery and they had
the tourniquet on for so long that when
they took to turn to get off to rush the
blood back down the new vein yes it's
called compartment syndrome I know it is
yeah so I got that real bad and I had to
do fasciotomies on both sides really
explain what component syndrome is for
people you don't know so pretty much
they the doctors explained to me in
layman's term as a hot dog that's the
microwave too long so it's too much
pressure
yeah because of the blood the blood flow
it hadn't been flowing for a long time
and all sudden that pressure if you like
blows the freaking leg up and you have
to slit it to to relieve that pressure
what happened with mine was that led to
necrosis of my muscle in my lower limb
because
the probably only need 13 hours without
blood flow for that to occur yeah so I
mean didn't it less than that - yeah so
I could have you know the tolerance that
you'd have needed probably maybe six
hours eight hours ten hours or whatever
and you could have had the same yeah so
they ended up having to take a big flap
on my muscle out of due to necrosis and
that flap of muscle was what was used to
lift my foot up yep so after that you
know obviously took about a year to walk
again all that [ __ ] but by the time I
had come to that point you know fast
forward two years my leg was worthless
man like my thigh was getting good and
all that and I was getting stronger but
my lower leg it just it I drug it around
with me there's no dose affliction or no
jury you can't lift the toes off the
ground now the reverse of a conference
yeah could you do calf raises
yes no no yeah calf raises yes yes yes
so I could go up on your toes I could go
up on my toes like upon your deal yeah
okay and so I had surgery to try to fix
that didn't work so hang on with we
you've had the artery and the vein
switch over the next year or two years
is is that hairy hub rehab rehab rehab
so I dislocated my knee and the incident
too so oh good six months was just
working that knee back oh my god yeah so
I love my knee and they never fixed it
so it just healed itself down yes all
scar tissue and stuff so I had this
little Vietnamese physical therapist and
she's just get up there and crank it man
and it was horrible
yeah so that was a good six months just
so it's the knee you know for me
watching my own experience of seeing
Armie rehab it's like what what you have
seen on Black Hawk Down and like you
know like sort of super American movies
but is it like that is it the
parallettes like with the onions and the
Zimmer frame like in the others and
helping you walk oh yeah yeah to sweat
him in the shaking oh yeah
abso-fucking-lutely and in the you know
you have to work hard in there if you
don't work hard and there you see the
drastic difference in people and they
don't do what they need to do in rehab
but if you're working hard in there
you're killing yourself I mean it sucks
really really sucks but did that for two
years
how to tendon transfer to try to get my
dorsiflexion back yep didn't didn't
really work and and also I was getting
hammer toe so because I didn't have the
ability to raise my my foot up or my
toes my
toes were slowly but surely going like
this yeah and older I got the more they
would do that and goes down extremely
painful yeah a lot of pain in my ankle
as well a lot of pain in my foot arch
okay so we got the point where I said I
can't can't [ __ ] do this I'm 22 years
old like I'm young I'm in physical
therapy just dying in and I'm looking at
these guys with prosthetics just doing
this crazy [ __ ] and I'm like how many
hours a week are you doing rehab for the
year or two years about four hours a
week I'm sorry four hours a day five
hours a day five days a week yeah it's a
full-time job just try to get your body
back to work because you have to do your
stretching for 30 minutes and you have
we train for an hour and then it's like
you're being a professional athlete so
just become a human
pretty much yeah yeah which is what it
takes I mean you have to that's mind
book so yeah it was really I'm thankful
so so so thankful to have been in the
rehab facility I was in with other
combat wounded veterans because I got to
see those young guys with their
prosthetics doing this crazy [ __ ] yeah
and I'm like that should be me like I
shouldn't be [ __ ] I'm bloody what
crazy [ __ ] with a dick would box jumps
and running and you know like just
things I would have never ran again you
know I would it just the things that I
wanted to do is a 22 year old athlete
yeah and so I went in and I said is
there anything we can do you know and
they mentioned elective amputation and I
nice I said you know they said you got
to think about it if you want to do it
we're willing to do it you know we've
done it before and we just can't promise
that it'll work out so I it took me
about a week how I was gonna say cuz
that decisions he's done lose a limb
yeah it's like they I actually read up
on shipped on online obviously in that
we jus and during that period didn't
that we yeah and and one of them likened
it to losing a family member and I
really much is you know because it's a
part of you yeah yeah and but after that
week when I made my decision it was done
you know I didn't and then you have to
wait six months they they have to make
sure that you're mentally sound right
it's not because I like them
like I'm gonna dye my hair yeah okay
lose a limb whatever yeah yeah so yeah I
went through the six months which is
good for me too because I shouldn't you
need to do the recessive yep six months
bro I'm like let's get this [ __ ] off
and is he doing that Paige was it
getting worse yeah absolutely
and and I was seeing I was feeling the
limitations of my body so two years
rehab right and I'm like every other
part of my body bite my thighs getting
stronger my bones getting stronger like
the vein Damon about the femurs back
like everything was coming together but
that yep and so I was at my I was at the
ceiling I had Noah let's get them off
run her off and on my dad to this day
it's the only surgery I came out of with
a smile on my face man it's the only one
Mighty Mite came out I'm just like I
knew it was new life it was like this is
my opportunity I had reached my max here
and now I knew that the ceilings just
exposed talking tenfold and oh yeah so
the funny thing about that is I have to
throw this out there some of my favorite
pictures but we actually had a
going-away party for my foot the night
before and all my buddies signed my foot
my dad was there he signed my foot my
sister was there and they put a little
coupon cutline on there don't cut bill
above this line I went in for the
surgery they're like oh my god yeah
who's this guy yeah so yeah got it have
to all they do it I mean just they
pretty much so go through because mine
is different the beautiful part about
having your leg and doing an elective
amputation is they have a lot of [ __ ] to
work with they've got they can choose
exactly exactly how they want to do it
what they want to use so if they have
the wherever is that the cut has been
made is that the optimal optimal oh
absolutely yeah after more for in terms
of legs okay so it's what's the specific
kind of amputation that it was if
they're just BK it's called below knee
amputation okay yeah there's no like
specific they're all the same
yep um the [ __ ] was like oh so they cut
it but they caught it right to the back
of the muscle right and then they take
it off so that big muscle flaps right
here right yeah then they take a little
piece of your tibia and they sew it into
your I guess you've got shitloads
ship airport I've seen it's like
Frankenstein [ __ ] yeah so they take a
linen to the rear I really always wanted
to six here we go rib on my forehead
maybe to see how it looks so they take a
little piece of tibia and they connect
your tibia and fibula at the bottom to
make a good little support yeah because
I took all the hurdle there's a lot of
pressure that's gonna now be going 70 in
F it's only two bones sticking straight
down you can imagine that it make me end
up hurting so they put the hurdle on the
end to act as kind of like look nice
little okay and then they bring that
flap up yep and so it okay pretty much
it
and yeah so got out and then it's back
to rehab you know another year rehab it
took me about a year to learn how to
walk right and about another year to run
right and then but it's four years of
rehab four years old coach we have two
years for the earlier two years to make
the decision you have another two years
off the back of it yep and so then I got
done with that and I mean it was the
best [ __ ] decision I ever could have
made I mean at the absolutely the things
I've done since then with my leg not
only blew my mind but it's just it it
proves me that I made the right decision
I'm happy with that you know I've never
regretted it not once and to be able to
look back now and be like man look at
all the things I've done yeah that I
never you know that you it sounds so
crazy it's such a reverse reverse
illogical decision for a normal person
hearing that to go I chose to lose a
limb and it's the best decision I could
have made yeah like for most people that
would be the you know it's heart sinking
one of the scariest things that you
could do and yet for you it's what's
giving you life let's see I had to live
through two years of the a of the Union
what it's like on the other side and the
other side is not [ __ ] fun okay and
what's it what's it like learning to
walk it's not much honestly something
much different you know wait got your
learn to walk again as an adult so it is
kind of different but it's a feeling
wise it's kind of one foot in front of
the other you know what I mean
but it's it takes a lot man a lot and a
lot of that has to do with not the nub
or the lower limb but you're the rest of
the body because it all has to adapt
yeah you don't realize how much you use
your foot and melly half
pushing off for everything so you
your core is like just oh yeah solid
yeah routers on there yeah because
you've got to you will have to balance
through your midline as opposed to using
dorsiflexion to re-stabilize right so
you've stabilized your whole lower leg
yeah mostly through your core yeah
as opposed to with your toes and with
your ankle so yeah that must have been a
real a real change of biomechanics for
you to Spearmon relearn that and it does
it takes a long time I actually had real
bad foot drop oh I'm sorry
real bad hip drop when I was walking
after I got amputated okay because you
you require a lot more as you said hip
and core movement and and act activity
than nor will you so it's real bad yeah
yeah like that so what she I did this
for six months man an hour every single
day she had me walk toward a mirror
walk back walk to her mirror so that I
could see what I was doing and talk me
through the rehabilitation is it we
backed on four hours a day yes
absolutely so and then once you get your
leg but that's the cool part is so like
I told you I was kind of like I had
reached my point about a year into my
first little stent yeah and I was just
kind of going through the motions after
that with the leg every it's every day
better better better more healing or
even after it by the time I was out I
ended my rehab there and medically
retired dude I was the guy in there that
other people were looking at like oh god
I find that one day which to me was
really [ __ ] cool that's amazing I was
one doing box jumps in there I was the
one doing sprints I would like it was
just one test it's like full circle of
life yeah so it was really [ __ ] cool
I was in a really good place than man
really really really good place and then
I met up here tired and I'm like man the
whole world's out it was like that new
feeling always I like that and then yeah
Laurel [ __ ] all over me but the issue
civilian life man you you it's funny how
that [ __ ] works you're just like so talk
me through reintegration
so that's your like I said there's this
excitement right like I'm gonna go to
college I'm gonna be a college kid I'm
gonna do all this stuff yeah you don't
[ __ ] realize how much support you
have at that medical matter military
medical community you don't realize how
much from the guy on there the baggage
to the rehabs to the friends you've made
there to the other combat when
veterans who understand what you're
going through without even having to say
a word to the nonprofit's editor there
to help you you have literally an army
of people there to support you and you
don't realize what it does for you until
you leave it and so I ended up going to
college in West Virginia cuz I wanted
just a fresh start you know I'm learning
something new didn't know anybody there
and it ended up being my downfall at
that time because I got there and there
was I mean I I didn't know who I was man
I didn't know who the [ __ ] I was because
my eat my life for years of it was rehab
that was that was my life it's not
getting better at 22 most people don't
know who they are
yeah let alone someone who's been in
this strangely insulated isolated very
unique very difficult to compare with
anyone elses experience situation yeah
and then you come out and then you've
got try and reintegrate yeah when you
have to imagine this too
you know you have a purpose military you
have a purpose deployed you have a
purpose even injury you have a purpose
I'm doing better yep when you lose all
of those purposes and you're on to the
next one that's when you're like oh [ __ ]
what am i what do I do you know how I've
got to go to this lecture I've got two
likes and I tell you what I just didn't
know who I was I didn't know where I was
going I didn't know who I was gonna
become how old how old we know at that
point what was I got hit at 21 X 2 weeks
before my 21st birthday and four years
of about 25 mid-20s yep yeah so I nya
plan on doing 20 years in the military
so I had no idea dude I no idea what I
wanted to do who I was gonna be a star
I'm fine to life none started going to
school for finance and I end up rushing
a fraternity because I said that I spent
two weeks there so unhappy so miserably
unhappy and alone in dealing with this
new onset PTSD that I was either about
to go home or just like I don't know I
didn't know I was out of options and so
I ended up rushing a fraternity which
was both good and bad obviously you know
I made friends and it gave me that
social aspect but it's not a good
environment for a veteran dealing with
PTSD to be around alcohol and drugs and
partying non-stop okay and so my life
kind of unraveled at that point a little
bit and and I got to a point I had spent
a year there and I said I gotta I gotta
get
I'm regressing yeah I'm not doing I'm
not I'm not becoming a better human
being yeah and so I had decided to move
to Florida and again one of the worst
years of my life the first year there
just cuz I knew no one will be doing
that in Florida yeah uh I started school
back down there to um but then I also at
that time I was traveling about two to
three weekends a month for this
nonprofit um it's a group of amputee
combat amputees who play softball so
that was really big for me and that's
actually the foundation of that sports
right okay so I was on that team played
ball for a year really enjoyed it gave
me some purpose and I was with those
guys which meant a lot but the guy that
led it was a rat [ __ ] and he like stole
money from the organization [ __ ] like
that he was using the guy so I I got out
of that and my best sport started from
that was because I was like I want to do
this the right way um so yeah the first
year in Florida yeah I was traveling
with that team and going to school
putting you know on and you know
resources in the community there wasn't
nothing I and support structures just
not that and I think for me the main
thing I needed was just veterans man
like oh there are other military people
just people that could understand me and
so that sports was started in 2012 that
was my second year in Florida okay I
lucked out had a mutual friend of
another combat wounded veteran and had a
combat wounded buddy of mine and all
three of us had really bad transitions
and realized that yeah while the
military medical center community has
all this support once you get to the
normal civilian community there's not is
it a little bit black and white
absolutely [ __ ] night and day as
opposed same general rum that sucks yeah
if I can so what does if you can try and
define what PTSD feels like can you try
and define it can you verbalize it the
only thing I can say I did this pretty
extensive therapy called art therapy art
therapy so it's not art art it's not
it's its accelerated resolution therapy
or something okay it's pretty much based
on eye movement so a lot of it is
internal you think about a lot of stuff
and you follow their hand with your eyes
because it allows you to kind of process
the thoughts better brilliant [ __ ]
search brilliant therapy
and what they what they said was when we
go through traumatic events we don't
even mean to do this but every event
thereafter runs through this filter a
filter of that event so you view and
experience things through that filter
because it's there it's this block in
your head and so you can't enjoy things
like normal you can't you you don't feel
compassion and love the normal feelings
that other people have you're just kind
of void of it all because everything is
being viewed to those filters and that
therapy they pretty much their whole
thing is they break down those phil try
to remove the lens so that you can view
everything with a fresh perspective okay
um but it's tough so it's PTSD it's just
it's all-encompassing man it's it's
always there and it's just um is it like
if someone's had anxiety does it feel
like anxiety a lot so that's the thing
about PTSD - is it manifests itself
differently for everybody so people have
nightmares you know I have nightmares
all the time - that's that's part of
PTSD some people can't do crowds I'm
alright with crowds it makes me
uncomfortable it's worse back in the day
you do some exposure therapy and you get
over it but there's a lot of different
that's why it's hard to explain exactly
what it is it's just such a it's such a
a ruthless affliction that the fact that
it's almost bringing back your your
first weaknesses so there's a really
interesting story from King Arthur in
the night to the roundtable and they've
got to go off got to look through the
dragon right you don't got to slay the
dragon and each of the night has to
enter the forest at the point which
looks darkest to him so each of them
they don't go in on one path each of
them has to walk around the forest until
they find the point at which looks
darkest day and that's what that feels
like to me that's that feels like
someone who it brings up like you'd find
it's capable of manifesting your
weakness like it's the Kryptonite what
you're craving but it's not everyone
else's so it's absolutely no matter so
there you that's a brilliant way to put
it actually I love that because it's
true so my some of my flaws my life has
been self-hatred and anxiety and the
PTSD takes both of those and [ __ ]
ramp them up Jackson moth until 11
and so I you know alcoholism drugs I
mean I was in it all I just needed to
Caillou had to cope somehow I had to
just erase it and numb the feelings a
lot of that goes back to what we were
talking about earlier where you have to
turn these emotions off for so frickin
long and utilize only the net the really
bad ones that you really shouldn't that
when you come back you don't it's not a
switch
you can't just switch them back on so I
had to learn over years and years did
you ever find yourself like feeling
aggressive again oh yeah dude I my in
West Virginia was big on this but my
fighting during my early 20s like mid to
like even later 20s was ridiculous
really just I was in pornhub I had said
enough that red already let red go oh
they're all okay nope yeah I get drunk
fight all the times flip out and so the
art therapy as I was saying I did that
about four years we gonna change me it
allowed me to feel those feelings again
it really brought all the emotions to
the forefront so you're following the
hunt and he being talked through you're
being talked through you're kind of
prompted but a lot of his thought
prompts so I actually did one of my
books thirty days I discuss it a lot
because it did mean a lot to me and I
wanted people to know about it but um so
if anyone's interested but yeah it's
it's very much here in your own head
you're thinking about and one of the
things they do at the end of every one
is so my childhood stuff we got very big
basis of that and I'd say it it really
helped me a lot in my childhood stuff
about ten times more than my military
stuff my military stuff has very much
been like this year year year long been
years long battle where and the child
stuff too but that was like
life-changing so do you think do you
think that mentally you're in a better
position now having gone through the art
therapy and started to move through the
PTSD with dealing with what happened
before you were deployed as well so I
think I think the art therapy getting me
through that childhood [ __ ] allowed me
to then go and battle the PTSD I was
like I was stuck so was it kind of like
you had to get okay I gotta get through
the first 16 years of life yeah and deal
with that stuff before I can actually so
you've got PTSD on
yes yeah you could have unit a that's
what it a TSP squid yeah yeah pretty
much and it's a really tricky thing to
[ __ ] figure out where do we stop
where do you [ __ ] start so I ended up
luckily I was getting long nasty way
there the end of every art therapy
session you envision yourself as a child
you know if you have childhood issues
yeah and you're holding your child view
by the hand and you're walking him
across the bridge the negativity is on
this side the positivity on it is on
this side and you walk them across this
bridge and you see a fire a big bonfire
and you stand next that bonfire and you
start throwing all that negative [ __ ] in
right and then you look down on your
younger self and they actually ask you
what would you tell you hunger you know
and I think I said believe in yourself
and don't let other people dictate how
you feel and she said okay good say that
to yourself in your head and then let
younger you start throwing stuff in the
fire too and it sounds [ __ ] weird and
hokey man and the first thing I did I
felt weird but I got a [ __ ] tell you
dude dude just existing in that it
changed me man
it changed me it was a very powerful
thing and I think obviously it had to do
with the whole session the session as a
whole and then ending it with that but
yeah there was something significant
about and you find it so the some of the
listeners will be practicing meditation
at the moment and some of the practices
that you go through and that can be
there can be difficult in the same way
that picking up a heavy weights
difficult but it's mental right and did
you find it testing to be able to start
visualizing that sort of stuff it's a
very specific way of thinking it's an
incredibly unique skill in the same way
as being able to do a snatch is a very
specific Mantle's of a physical skill
you're being asked to do something which
is very very fine and discreet mentally
yeah did you find did you have to
cultivate all the time
did you have a depth certainly but the
thing about our therapy too is that it's
very quick its accelerated resolutions
here if you call them for a reason it
works quickly so yeah the first session
first few sessions you're like okay
basically time but yeah but you also in
order for that to work you have to be
open to it you have to if you're going
there thinking oh this is [ __ ] hokey
[ __ ] yeah it's not gonna work so
yeah even though I in my head I'm like
okay what
and when I went in there I've said every
time I said you're gonna [ __ ] the
musician you're gonna be open mind and
you're gonna I mean look at you know to
go back to the decision to lose the limb
like you know you had done your research
you'd read through and then you go I'm
gonna go for this like this is all or
nothing you know and you know 100%
commitment I think is there must be a
lot of people who have maybe gone to do
our therapy and have had that doubt in
the back of their mind and then they
haven't elicited that same result that
you did yeah so I was unfortunate
because it really it was it was
fantastic it was incredible so it's not
the basis of your recovery yeah because
I like I said I think it knocked out
that childhood PTSD you know it allowed
me to move past that okay and again so
did you find kind of like eating Lay's
of a cake did you find different
sensations and different tastes as we
moved through the layers so you think
it's like a flood gates have been opened
right so where I never felt love or
happiness or joy or anything like that
in the years prior I felt them like I'm
an infinite level afterward it was weird
so like was I be watching overwhelming
yes but it'll be kind of a beautiful way
because I was feeling again and so like
one of the things is it's so ridiculous
but like I'll watch a YouTube episode of
The Voice or something and you'll have
somebody who's like maybe they're meek
or they had some terrible childhood and
they go in there [ __ ] just kill it
yeah I cry about with now I weep like a
[ __ ] baby that would have never
happened back in the day ever
yeah and that was one of the big things
I just feel mortified meaning it's a
yeah okay and so yeah it was huge it was
significant through the art therapy um
what's next after that well so of the
art therapy and that sport started about
the same time so I also found my purpose
again at that point so tell me tell me
about that Sports it's what I want to
get onto so vet sports again the bad
should the [ __ ] transition right you
know and then that bad organization if I
was like you know I know this works
bringing veterans together
and know this works and having some sort
of active activity yeah but and what if
we did it the right way now
that what if we provided it within the
communities where people could are
returning to I mean they're
transitioning to these communities how
cool would it be to have a little club
there so like I said the three of us
came up with the idea of having the
community-based clubs that revolve
around sports athletic events community
involvement we help other charities as
well through donating our time and then
um you know get-togethers events just
bringing them together social events and
as we started that sports our first club
was in DC and then I started one down in
Tampa which is funny you know like I
didn't have any friends at there at that
time right yeah I made all my friends in
Florida from that sports so yeah that
was growing and really becoming
something and so I had that new purpose
yeah I was still battling absolutely I
still battle this day that [ __ ] never
goes away but I think you you know it's
just progress yeah its progress even
little progress is is huge when you go
through that kind of life and what's the
process of starting a sporting
organization for veterans like what do
you how do you find them well it lots of
recruiting a lot of recruiting methods
be a student veteran organizations yeah
I had to learn all this that's so that
was kind of the funny thing you know it
was a lot of pressure and it definitely
in there those early years yeah because
I have a lot of self-hatred and
self-doubt stuff like that it was tough
because I would big little tasks right
yeah because you really you know what
can I do this you know is it worthy is
it we're gonna team anyone else yeah so
yeah you you end up I had to learn it
all and uh and but we did it I mean we
have we've recruited through colleges
and VA s and other nonprofits and it's
just it's been cool man what are the
sports that you guys anything so we
really we at the end of the day we want
to know what they want to do so if you
have a club say we have a club in East
Texas and you want to do some skeet
shooting than they do skeet shooting
whereas in California if your crew wants
to do surfing then we do surfing you
know it's all dependent on the or the
area and what the need is but we like to
keep it mixed you know we do softballs
you know kickball skeet shooting
again everything we do everything we
definitely focus more on team sports
aspect of it there's a lot of nonprofits
out there that are helping and doing
good stuff we believe in the team sports
aspect of it because it kind of gives me
that new goal yeah brings you together
that allows you to work together again
and part of a team is big military thing
obviously so it gives you that feeling
again does it feel a little bit like a
brotherhood again it is Brotherhood
absolutely any guy invests words to tell
you the best sports is a brother I hate
seeing Brotherhood because it's a
sisterhood as well but it's a family it
is an absolute family and that's what we
wanted it to be we didn't start out it
out wanting to be a big or you know an
organization where you can't reach out
to the founder and say hey tell me about
that sport did you did it yeah so how
many locations even so [ __ ] that's I'm
like I took a step back this year right
so like all this shit's happening now
it's like I just hit my kid off to
college right yeah I did all the things
that I did you feel like it's its own
monster it is no I'm not yeah I'm like
it just runs he told Adam yeah it does
it something Randy Thorpe is our
president on and he's a fantastic he's
another combat wounded veteran who
co-founded it with me and an incredible
human being and he is absolutely the
reason vest words is where it is today
no I've done my part and I've done
everything that I can to bring it to
where it is but Randy especially with
this new growth it goes to him I mean
we're we're in a lot of places so just
to try to name them all Michigan Killeen
Texas Jacksonville the Panhandle Tech
Tampa we just did one in Northville fort
long game you're [ __ ] remember it - up
in Michigan DC Westchester New York
they're everywhere man New Mexico
looking hundreds of people yeah Oh
thousands thousands of veterans yeah it
blows my mind do you have any idea how
many people have been a like from start
to finish you've been a member of that
sports like if you both I don't have a
specific number but thousands absolutely
thousands yeah and the effect that it's
had on reintegration and all the rest
today is probably gonna be pretty
profound
I don't think so yeah I mean I think the
proof is in the pudding for sure but
from what I've seen yeah I mean we've
it's been beautiful man we've seen a lot
of people who were
in the exact seed I was in who just come
out slowly but surely 20 it's a process
one of my best friends now is actually
one of these guys who just showed up one
day and it's like this timid like you
watches first it doesn't really talk to
anybody and just checks it out and then
the next week they come and maybe they
talk to a few people the next week
they're like hey can I get a uniform you
know it's like they build to this point
and then like like my best friend now
yep he i seethen him the change and I
don't know where some of those guys
would be now if it weren't for it which
is a good feeling to have must be
incredibly empowering yeah you know to
take your experience and then also your
passion which was sports and somehow
create something that's meaning and puts
people on a different trajectory and
yeah yeah at the end of the day that's
work that's our ultimate goal I know if
you guys still got the it's kind of like
the baseball logo but it's with the
artificial like sports like is that do
you know that the silhouette oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah is that stay on your
emblem that's mine make sure it's in the
show notes
if anyone who's just listening needs to
check this out because it is so [ __ ]
cool yeah I love that thing it's so cool
is that who's that that's me is that you
yeah yeah yes so just like halfway
through this way up a baseball bat but
you can see the back leg is a prosthetic
yeah yeah it's cool the kangaroo kind of
yeah yeah arch foot man that's it's just
sick I think I when I first first never
saw that I was like that I love it I
just love the branding I thought I
thought it was really really good
so that sports now is purely us-based
are you aware of any organizations which
is similar elsewhere in the world we are
no and an international obviously I have
taken a step back so I'm not gonna make
these decisions so much anymore I'll
probably put them out there and see what
but I would love to you international at
one point like a UK about sports club
for me to have my - man they stop they
pop up you guys fought behind beside US
Canada Italy there's so many people that
I saw there that contributed and a lot
of them don't get the same benefits that
we do a lot of them don't get the same
treehouse game so if you if you were to
look at you've said that reintegrating
into normal society there's maybe some
work to be done that
but you sing the praises of the
immediate reintegration and absolutely
what are your impressions of that in
other countries do you think America
leads the way with that absolutely
that's a really big engine yep okay I
know I know some UK guys who lost limbs
overseas who are not taken care of and
the way they should be
Germany is terrible really well
unfortunately due to their past they
view their military with this tapes as
ask us yeah and when they get injured
they're just they're left that's
terrible
defenseless pretty much that's terrible
so yeah I mean International for me
obviously we have a long way to go we're
a very small organization completely
grassroots um but yeah I mean 20 years
from now if there's less sports UK best
sports Canada I'd be the happiest
[ __ ] on earth I bet yeah yeah
that's awesome
so you found some meaning with that and
then you started writing so that's
another side of the [ __ ] story man
and it's so weird hold on real quick can
you tell him that what time is it now
yeah can you tell I mean it's probably
gonna be another 20 okay oh yes so the
right tell me about the right so here's
the thing I've always been a writer I've
always loved it I've always loved
reading obviously is it surprising you
know like oh my god you know like hyper
masculine and all that stuff but then
you you've got this other side's if I
grow any creative no it's it's I grew up
writing lyrics dude fifth grade fourth
grade I was writing lyrics and I was so
I was playing music and [ __ ] you know
horrible music but like that it was I
was always the creative type I'd always
felt empowered by utilizing the written
word to feel something yeah and I've
always been a reader Aurel Stein Stephen
King I grew up on that [ __ ] I would
devour those books and so I always loved
it I didn't write when I was in the
military I lost I lost my passion for
writing when I was in the military and
when I was healing up yeah and I had to
kind of discover that passion again so I
mean I'm taking finance in school PTSD
[ __ ] [ __ ] and down in Florida first
year in Florida this time yeah PTSD is
rough I'm miserable man and I hate my
classes I'm going to classes every day
and I'm I hate it
yeah and I'm like no it's not
stimulating you know intellectually so
I'm like bro what are you doing
you're medically retired you have an
organization that you know you found in
you you care about that's giving you
purpose why are you not chasing a bike
why are you not doing what makes you
happy yeah and so I switch my major
right then there to creative writing
okay and just with the hopes that
someday I'd maybe get an opportunity at
that time I thought maybe I'd try to do
some like ship writing contest
screenplay contest and see where it took
me a year into my creative writing after
I had switched it
I got reached out to you by Michael
Stokes Michael Stokes is a pretty
renowned photographer who one of his
campaigns or one of his passion projects
was shooting combat winning amputees but
mail forms so very like masculine sexy
photos both problem with prosthetics in
them yeah it was it was trying to take
away from the process it was there
beautiful photos and when I first saw
two guys did it before I did and I saw
those about a year before Michael
reached out to me and I was just like
just no yes and and I was like man I'd
love to do that but never thought I
could yeah next you know fast for a year
and I go into my facebook Messenger and
it says Michael Stokes and I'm like [ __ ]
I open the message man and he invited me
to come shoot and I was just gambling
around the hotel room yeah I said [ __ ]
yeah that's for quite wild I you so he
hit me up I think it was July and I shot
in December and we were supposed to I
think I supposed to shooting in October
this is a OH
first and only time in my life where I
was like I ate everything I was supposed
to I trained track Microsoft yep yeah
and I look [ __ ] fantastic photos are
unbelievable they'll be in the show
notes oh yeah I was five it was five
months of that and I hated my I hated
everything about my life I [ __ ] hated
LeMans you know it is it doesn't matter
whether you've been a war or not no one
likes dying no no one wants to be
unendurable so yeah so I ended up doing
that shoot and then I use real big in
the romance community a lot of fans and
that so I started getting traction in
the romance community and had no like
you were talking about it last night
about like you had no idea this world
existed I just got thrown into it man
you open Pandora's box man with this
with the road it was beautiful it's a
yeah actually it's a fantastic community
that you just nobody really not a lot of
people know about so yeah I stumbled on
the rubble tumble down a rabbit hole got
my first couple covers and then
I had a website at that time and I had
some of my short stories on there and an
author who had published two books read
my short stories really liked them and
had a military romance storyline that
she didn't think she could just do
justice to okay reached out to me asked
me if I'd like to co-write it with her
how daunting was that [ __ ] terribly
daunting was that is that up though with
like forget that sports forget he's a
leg like I got to write a book
absolutely [ __ ] this Carrie Thomas
mental task I've ever done my life got
tough furthermore yes definitely afraid
and I will say this it's if I didn't
have a co-writer co-author that kind of
walk me through um I don't know how long
it would have been before I tried even
to write a book even being in the
romance community as a model yeah I
don't know how long it would have taken
so many lives it's daunting I don't
think it's very many guys that make that
transition right it must be difficult to
be both a coda model and an author well
unfortunately a lot of guys have been
and it's successful well no I
for me I I was a writer before I was a
model man I I am a writer through and
[ __ ] I don't nothin to model as well
I just happen to model as well whereas
there are some that go from cover model
to writer for money's sake because they
see that off your life follow me on this
side and that disgusts me and so I I
actually for years but look pretty much
my whole career until about a year ago I
had to fight that battle that kind of
that label I was labeled the model
turned writer know my guys know still
around yeah I was going to school for
writing before I ever took a photo sit
in front of the cup and so yeah I
finally now I'm at the point where I
think people see me or see my name or
your penis writer it's not it's writers
model writer slash model not model slash
writer yeah which is cool that's
important distinction I guess when you
want absolutely when you want your work
to be viewed with artistic integrity yep
you need to make sure that that's that
that's the way that it's done so you how
many books have you published now so
I've got two co-written books out I'm
working on my third co-written one now
and I've got two four four solo books
and I'm then you going super secret one
that's the co-written the unwritten one
that's super secret and no one's gonna
get to find out what that is it's gonna
be last-minute yeah I'm hoping to come
out with that one about September August
okay now about September and
yeah pretty much I'm just gonna drop it
and then for the oh I'm so pumped dude
and it's not only that but the story
itself has been very writing so
difficult man it really is writer's
blocks a very real thing so there's
times I'll sit there and nothing I'll
come out or it'll be really clunky and
just just what this one it's just like
straight from my brain to my your tips
so I'm really excited to get it out
there yeah that's fantastic yeah so I
mean it's it's such an interesting story
this is one of the reasons that I wanted
to get you on to just hear the arc of so
many different things but I think you
know if you were to try and if you try
and work out a consistent narrative of
what's happened throughout what you've
been doing it's been a commitment to
decisions it seems it's that I'm going
to do something in its a full dick and
balls like the full length yeah and I'm
gonna go for it yeah and you know like
I'm gonna decide to lose it like I'm
gonna decide to move out and go to
school I'm also going to decide to go to
a different one you know for me
certainly I can pontificate about a
decision like which [ __ ] yogurt to
have for five minutes in the supermarket
right and like you know that that
ability to that foresight and that
ability to choose I think is is really
really important because there must be
so many people so many veterans and and
other people in life that they just
waver but in this sort of gray area
between two things and that's when
nothing gets done right yeah it's
actually pretty interesting man because
you know I like I said self-doubt
self-hatred are things that I battle
significantly or yes up top but said
self-doubt is in terms of my work so
like doubting my abilities and doubting
my storylines and doubting that when it
comes to decision making now my whole
life it's been I make that decision and
there's no [ __ ] looking back you be
prepared to outsource decision making
like if I need some decisions to
absolutely
you want to get you want to get the
BlackBerry yogurt and you want to go for
the yeah I'm a professional decision I
think that you could be but yeah I don't
like living in that world look like what
if right well what if sucks man because
you can't you can't it doesn't like me
I'm I
separately wanted to play college ball
man I even tried out for University of
Tampa after losing my leg and did well
but not good enough
yep always been a dream of mine and it's
something I do you know I think about
McMahon that would have been nice to
have that life boat what what the [ __ ]
can I do about it now man yeah I can't
go back in time I can't do anything
about so I hate living in that world of
what if it just does me no good and
really my anxiety it cook tries it
through the roof so I've learned yeah
when it comes to big decision life
decision making it's like for one put a
lot of time and research into it make
sure you make a solid decision to when
you make that [ __ ] decision stick
with it commit to it commit to it
Foley man I think that's it's such a
lovely such a lovely sentiment to have
and when you think you know hopefully
some of the people that are listening
it's I think it's very easy to the
rhetoric you look at how hard someone
else's life is look at how much
someone's been through but their life's
completely different to mine but when it
comes to stuff like decision making and
committing to your values and and moving
forward and doing what it is that you
want to do because I think a lot of the
time people people know what it is that
they want they just don't have the
bravery to pursue it
look what they're so worried about all
the possible outcomes right like it's
that that's where people get caught I
think it's because they're just they
know what they want to do but they're so
like stuck in the future what-ifs that
they can't make that decision because
they're like what if that happens what
if it happen it can happen this can
happen it's like yeah it might do so
that's it's the leg and I maybe honestly
that leg probably then probably that leg
decision was what led me to where I am
now because that was one where I mean
the what-ifs for that are significant I
mean you can get an infection how many
things can go wrong a lot of things can
go wrong you know I could have ended up
worse very much so but the thing is I
did enough research I put enough time
and talked to enough other amputees
where I said I think I have a great
chance of being fine here I know in my
heart of hearts that I have the work
ethic to get there so [ __ ] let's [ __ ]
do this whereas you know if that in that
decision if I was like kind of wish wish
wish II washi yeah I mean what do you do
I would probably have been in limbo for
another two years until I finally
decided to cut it off
you know mmm so yeah that probably was
the first though that was the nuts that
saw the deck of cards just saw that fall
from that right once you have once you
make the decision to cut off your own
leg like every to say after that's
pretty basic well I'm not know let's
finish it that can you tell the
listeners whether can find you online
and where they can go after your books
absolutely yeah so BT urilla comm is Rui
si you are our UEL a.com you can find
all my covers on there some of my short
stories everything's kind of their best
sports thought of work for anything
that's what's related we have everything
up on there ways to help more about who
we are and what we do and then Facebook
obviously be Chiarello on Facebook be
T's book battalion is where we talk all
things book book related and yeah
Twitter at BTU army I mean they're all
out there amazing yeah man I appreciate
time hey thank you so much for you
appreciate you bro
[Music]